el agua lo cubre Todo en esta región de
Nigeria solo los techos de las casas
quedaron al descubierto el país más
poblado de África vive las peores
inundaciones en décadas con 90.000
hogares Y comercios han negados y miles
de hectáreas de cultivos devastadas la
población teme ahora la falta de
alimentos energía y combustible más de
un millón de nigerianos se han tenido
que desplazar desde el inicio de la
temporada de lluvias
a lo largo de 60 o 70 años nunca había
visto algo así así que tal vez tenga que
ver con el cambio climático
qué es lo que mejor conoce la tecnología
para definirlo o probarlo
las lluvias torrenciales también
llegaron al vecino Chad tiendas de
personas huyeron de sus hogares cargando
sus pocas pertenencias sobre la cabeza
puesto que los ríos y canales se
desbordaron inundando varias áreas de la
capital
las autoridades deberían asumir su
responsabilidades construyendo diques
sostenibles para protegernos de las
aguas del río no podemos entender que
cada vez nos abandonen a nuestra suerte
durante la temporada de lluvias nos
encontramos en la misma situación de
desastre vamos de inundación en
inundación estamos cansados de todo esto
y en el norte de Camerún las
inundaciones también arrasaron con
cultivos y viviendas
aprietan desanés y después de tantos
años sigue habiendo este tipo de
inundaciones y la gente se mueve de un
lugar a otro como si fuéramos refugiados
no está bien
África subsaharianas se ve gravemente
afectada por la emergencia climática que
pone en riesgo el sustento de vida de
millones de africanos